what we're going to do in this video is
talk about a relatively recent US
Supreme Court case and this is the
United States versus Lopez and the
decision was made in 1995
and this is significant because many of
the cases we have talked about are
things that broaden the power of the
federal government while the decision in
United States versus Lopez which was a
split decision it was a five-to-four
decision put some limits on federal
power and so just to understand what
happened in 1990 the US Congress passes
the gun-free school zones Act of 1990
and it says it shall be unlawful for any
individual knowingly to possess a
firearm at a place that the individual
knows or has reasonable cause to believe
is a school zone and in 1992 a high
school student in San Antonio Texas
Alfonso Lopez carries a concealed
firearm into his high school he is
arrested and then he is eventually
prosecuted under the gun-free school
zones Act of 1990 a federal law and he
is tried in a federal court his lawyers
say hey this is unconstitutional the
federal government does not have the
right to regulate whether someone
carries a gun into a school or not while
the federal government says hey yes we
can do this because look at the United
States Constitution we the federal
government have a right to regulate
interstate trade and remember what
McCulloch versus Maryland told us from
the Necessary and Proper Clause anything
that is a means to regulate say another
enumerated power like interstate the
power to regulate interstate trade that
is also constitutional for the federal
government but then you could imagine
Lopez's lawyer said hold on a second
that is a very tenuous connection if
you're trying to connect the notion of
firearms in schools and school safety to
interstate commerce well you could
connect almost anything to interstate
commerce which would mean that between
the Necessary and Proper Clause the
implied powers and the enumerated powers
of regulating interstate commerce well
then the federal government could just
regulate anything
and so it eventually gets appealed all
the way to the United States Supreme
Court and in a split five to four
decision the United States Supreme Court
decides in favor of Lopez that the
gun-free school zones Act of 1990 at
least as it was originally written was
indeed unconstitutional that it's an
overreach of federal power and to
appreciate the majority's thinking
here's an excerpt of the decision by
William Rehnquist who was the chief
justice and who was in the majority and
he wrote to uphold the government's
contentions here the contention that the
government is making that it is
constitutional to regulate the
possession of firearms in a school we
have to pile inference upon inference in
a manner that would bid fair to convert
congressional authority under the
Commerce Clause to a general police
power of the sort retained by the states
so Rehnquist is saying hey look if we
say that the regulation of firearms is
connected to interstate commerce somehow
because it somehow affects the economy
between states
well then almost anything if you if you
layer pile inference upon inference then
that would give the right to the federal
government to police almost anything a
type of police power
that's generally retained by the states
admittedly some of our prior cases have
taken long steps down that road giving
great deference to congressional action
and you could go all the way back to
McCulloch versus Maryland he's saying
yeah the Supreme Court has ruled many
times in favor of the federal government
having a broad understanding of implied
powers the broad language in these
opinions has suggested the possibility
of additional expansion but we decline
here to proceed any further so they're
drawing the line in this decision on the
expansion of congressional power to do
so would require us to conclude that the
Constitution's enumeration of powers
does not presuppose something not
enumerated and that there never will be
a distinction between what is truly
national and what is truly local this we
are unwilling to do so he's saying hey
look if we took the government side on
this there's no end there
isn't any thing that the federal
government can't do and then there won't
be a distinction between what is truly
national and what is truly local I'll
let you decide but it's a fascinating
case and it's really important in this
discussion on power between states and
the federal government because this was
a decision that kind of drew a line and
said okay you know we can't let the
federal government have an unlimited
number of powers based on just being
able to tie inference upon inference to
something like the Commerce Clause